the ps plus free games for february have
been announced the next three call of
duty titles are reportedly confirmed for
playstation and more
sony has announced february's free
playstation plus games for subscribers
and there are three games on the way
these will be ea sports ufc 4 planet
coaster console edition which i'm
looking forward to and tiny tina's
assault on dragon keep a wonderland's
one shot adventure all three will be
available starting tuesday february 1st
with the first playstation story refresh
of the month ea sports ufc 4 is the
latest entry in ea's mma series which
was originally released in 2020 planet
coaster console edition is a park
building game that lets you create a
fantasy park of your dreams tiny tina's
assault on dragon keep is a standalone
campaign for borderlands 2 featuring
fantasy battles and co-op which comes to
ps plus just ahead of tiny tina's
wonderlands in march 2022
with just a few more days left in
january be sure to grab this month's ps
plus freebies now before they expire
this includes persona 5 strikers dirt 5
and deep rock galactic
activision blizzard has reportedly
committed to releasing the next three
entries in the call of duty series on
playstation following its impending
buyout by microsoft according to
bloomberg this year's call of duty game
which is rumored to be a new entry in
the modern warfare series developed by
infinity ward will launch on playstation
consoles the other two are treyarch's
project that is currently in development
as well as a new iteration of 2020's
free-to-play title call of duty warzone
both of those projects are expected to
launch in 2023 as far as pod releases
top activision employees are also
reportedly considering not making call
of duty an annual franchise anymore and
spacing out releases microsoft's phil
spencer spoke with sony last week and
confirmed that existing contracts will
be honored and that call of duty will
remain on playstation there was a lot of
speculation about what spencer really
meant but now we have an idea once these
next three call of duty games launch on
playstation then microsoft could move
forward in making the franchise an
exclusive for its xbox and pc ecosystem
how do you feel about not having a new
cod each year do you think it would be
better to space them out let me know why
in the comments
the uncharted series is back in action
with the legacy of thieves collection
releasing this week on playstation 5 and
the tom holland uncharted movie coming
to theaters in february given all the
big developments for the series lately
some might be wondering if naughty dog
might return to the franchise with a new
installment in the series someday sean
escage a naughty dog veteran who worked
on uncharted 4 and the lost legacy most
recently said in an interview with
gamesradar that the team has a never say
never attitude about it and stated
uncharted is a franchise we love that
the studio loves it's a world we want to
see more of back in 2016 a thief's in
director neil druckmann has said that
he'd be happy to see another studio take
over but only if they were able to nail
the essence of uncharted
as for what naughty dog is making next
druckman said recently that he is dying
to discuss the company's next projects
one of the games is likely the last of
us multiplayer project that has been in
the works for some time but druckman
also teased that the studio might make
the last of us 3 or a new ip altogether
which would you rather see from naughty
dog a new uncharted a new last of us or
something new altogether let me know in
the comments and as always leave a like
subscribe and tune in tomorrow for
another episode of gamespot news